I have buddy my name is miles ward
I run the solutions architecture
practice for Google cloud worldwide and
I have to tell you I've been working
with the team at Twitter now for two
years and I cannot be more proud to be
on stage to show you and help you see
what it is that they are doing with our
platform they have prepared a
presentation to really unfold how it is
that they're adopting Google cloud and
I'm just incredibly excited about this
moment so to really take you through it
one to introduce Derek Lyon runs runs VP
of engineering here at Twitter thank you
so much so I'm going to talk a little
bit about our journey to the cloud we
actually didn't know initially that we
were gonna do Hadoop that was something
we discovered during the process so I'm
gonna start out talking a little bit
about our infrastructure in general and
how we did the evaluation here so first
of all Twitter's infrastructure we were
founded in 2006 that may seem familiar
that's the year that like some of the
first cloud services started we were
actually slightly before them so cloud
was not a choice than anybody was making
at that time over time we've grown up to
be a global scale application which is
quite large you know there are other
larger applications out there but but
not very many actually Twitter relative
to other large websites has some very
unique performance and scale
considerations especially on we do a lot
of real-time stuff as you'll see our
data platform is pretty large as well
and over time over the last 12 years you
know we've we've grown our footprint and
our data centers and a lot of us built
to purpose you know we have enough scale
that you know we're not buying you know
Hardware off the racks or buying stuff
that you know is built specifically for
the workload that's running so it's
relatively efficient which I think makes
cloud adoption a little bit more
challenging for us as a decision than it
would be if you were startup buying
stuff from you know a retail website so
the strategic questions that we set out
to answer first of all what's the
long-term mix of cloud in our portfolio
you know we're big enough that we can
afford to do stuff relatively cost
effectively in the down
Center at the same time doing zero
things on the cloud seems probably not
enough but there's a pretty wide range
of opinions within Twitter around what
exactly that ratio was second question
is which cloud vendor should we use and
obviously the choices I think well
anticipated here but you know if really
important ones first organizationally is
also how do we become confident in this
decision right so there's a range of
opinions inside of Twitter around what
works well what doesn't work well people
have had different experiences at
different companies how do we actually
collect real data and make a real
engineering decision about what we're
gonna do in a way that we can defend and
organize people around and then you know
we started this evaluation in 2016
so as my elements mentioned it's been
about two years we'll share some numbers
some of those are perhaps a little bit
dated right now so as you as you listen
to the talk it encourage you to think
about the process as much as the results
and you know your mileage will of course
vary and some of the providers have
improved since then so the more tactical
questions that we're trying to answer
you know and I don't want to minimize
these by calling these tactical some of
these are actually the hardest and most
important questions number one is you
know what how feasible is it to move you
know either Twitter or some large
portion of Twitter to the cloud what's
the cost of that you know how do you
identify the workloads that you can
actually separate if you're going to do
a hybrid cloud model using pretty mature
software that hasn't anticipate of the
hybrid cloud model previously do you
really tech things as you do that right
or do you do list and shift and then how
do you put all this together into an
actionable plan with a you know budget
and the timeline and everything else
that's a massive problem so 2016
you know the our process maybe is a
little bit different than some people so
you know if you're somebody who has a
renewal and a data center coming up and
you need to make a decision quickly this
may not be exactly the right process for
you you know we had the opportunity to
make a patient and rigorous decision and
at our scale you have small errors and
calculations or large numbers in an
absolute sense so you'll see that we we
tried to be very detailed in our
decision-making so we knew that we
wanted to look at this we started out
deciding that we wanted to analyze this
on a workload basis so
started out defining the baseline
requirements for each of our workloads
we actually sent our peas out to all the
different providers that we thought
might be candidates for us and then in
each case we analyzed how that workload
would run each workload would run on
each provider and then you know built a
plan and aggregated here's a little bit
of the timeline
I'll kind of walk through this you can
see a lot of the core engineering work
that we'll talk about in the evaluation
process was here in fall of 2016 and
then you know there's quite a bit of
iteration and you know organizational
approvals and other sorts of things and
then where we are now we actually just
started our migration process so April
was you know kind of the official deal
assigned we're doing it and June is
effectively when you know we had
everybody in seats and really kind of
working on this this is pretty new yeah
so the different workloads that we
looked at you know this looks probably
pretty comprehensive it was intended to
be pretty comprehensive we looked at
real time systems we looked at no sequel
systems we looked at messaging objects
tour database general-purpose computing
and batch computing and each one of
these you know we'll talk about the
evaluation process for Hadoop because
that's the one that we found interesting
and that's the one you know where we're
actually gonna change what we're doing
as a result of what we found but we did
a similar analysis for each one of these
actually so for each of these workloads
what we looked at was you know kind of
two high-level options right do we do we
just use you know there's pride or doing
something better than we are we should
just use what they're doing and game
over or you know should we run our own
service there and if we do run it there
do we just lift and shift what we're
doing today
or do we architect in some way because
the provider has some primitives that
perform differently or offer different
functionality that's interesting to us
the interesting note here at the bottom
is you know and this is something I
encourage you to think about not every
user of that platform will take the same
approach right so like a very small
scale database might benefit from just
using a provider managed service if it
happens to be like the Twitter graph or
something that may be a little harder to
run that
the provider service so you may you may
choose to segment a little bit depending
on the scale complexity and uniqueness
of the workload so for the evaluation
this is kind of a generic process this I
would you know if you're gonna take a
photo this is probably a good one you
know so we started out with functional
testing to see just make sure that all
of our software would run we did find a
few minor bugs there that was a little
bit less interesting though the core of
the process though was doing micro
benchmarking for each resource that we
depended on and we used that to then
figure out what the candidate
configurations would be right so which
class of storage do we you know gives
the performance characteristics that you
know we want for this type of workload
once we had a couple candidate
configurations for each workload we then
moved on to macro benchmarking where we
actually ran large-scale application
benchmarks to actually see how the
workload would perform in a realistic
way we tried to do some scale testing in
some cases we couldn't go to full
twitter scale but we tried to go within
an order of magnitude if we could you
know as close to reality as we could
that's actually a one that a lot of
people don't do because it cost a little
bit of money but I would encourage you
to do that we did find stuff there we'll
talk about that later and then it this
was kind of a cool thing that we did
each time we found something we showed
it back to the provider you know with
the scripts that we were using and
everything else and asked them to
validate that the numbers we were seeing
or what they expected and then you know
we continued to iterate on this process
so you know the kind of core first run
through that process was about two and a
half months to do this on multiple
providers so it actually didn't take
that long I would encourage you to do
that the the next like well over a year
here was us trying to get to a very
precise answer so you know if you're
looking for an 8020 solution that the
two or three-month approach is pretty
reasonable for an 80/20 solution if you
need higher accuracy than that you know
expect to run through this process a
couple times so coming out of that you
know we built an overall cloud plan that
we wanted to then assess this included
candidate architectures for each of
these workloads that was driven by you
know the benchmarking that we've done
before
from there we tried to work backwards
into what the migration plan would look
like for each of those workloads the
dependencies between the workloads on
each other and the time
and then we created some financial
projections associate with that which
I'll talk about in just a second and
then you know there's some other
business considerations as well so the
financial modeling this we did a pretty
elaborate version of this I'm very
grateful to our finance team for their
support in this we looked at a 10-year
horizon that seems ridiculously long but
that's actually the asset lifetime of a
lot of the assets that you're comparing
against right like a data center that's
a typical lease duration and we did find
that if you look at something shorter
term you're very sensitive to like how
recently you just bought servers or you
know like when your lease is coming up
so it was important to do and not long
enough time horizon that we weren't
subject to those timing effects we
looked at multiple different cloud
scenarios we also looked at our on
premises scenario and in the on-premises
case we also you know made sure to layer
in improvements that we knew we could do
so if there's a tech refresh it's gonna
help us there
you know we've layered all that in the
costs actually kind of interestingly
segmented out into like a migration
period cost where you're running
duplicate infrastructure and you're very
sensitive to the time of the migration
plan and you know if you can cut things
over at exactly the right time and it's
actually quite constrained and
complicated and then the longer-term you
know it was kind of past the point where
we had immediate visibility into you
know what exactly was gonna happen so
there you know there's long term curves
like Moore's Law for the CPU we looked
at you know full historical pricing for
you know how providers have been cutting
costs and stuff and then tried to layer
that into the long term projection to
get a sense for how costs were revolving
on a relative basis and then this one
adds a lot of work but it was important
for us because the numbers were so big
we actually maintained two independent
models with separate calculation paths
so that you know if somebody makes an
error we can actually see the the model
error there because the two models
wouldn't converge in that case and
getting those to converge was a fair bit
of work so what we found you know this
is kind of the key takeaway and then
we'll go through the process that got us
here and immediate all in migration and
Twitter scale was expensive you know we
found it would be more expensive
especially we didn't optimize as we went
it was gonna block a ton of teams for a
long period of time and distract us from
other stuff that we thought we needed to
work on as a business and there was a
lot of risk associated with that so if
we got halfway through that migration
and
something was going sideways that was a
pretty big problem what we did discover
coming out of that is that in cases
where we can embrace a new architecture
or transform something and really take
advantage of something in cloud is
providing that we don't already have
there may be more value there and so we
decided to pick something smaller we
actually could do a meaningful
transformation with learn from that and
then you know I'm sure our strategy will
evolve over time
Hadoop was the workload that we picked
because we actually found some very
interesting things there and will and 10
will do a rerp picture as part of the
migration and one cool outcome out of
this actually so there's a range of
opinions about you know what the
strategy should be I think it's actually
clarified a lot for us you know we know
what we're moving and we're able to now
fully invest in moving that and doing a
good job with that we also know what
we're not moving anytime soon and we're
able to invest more in you know running
that in the data center as well so it's
no longer you know this debate about
like should we really invest in that is
that going to disappear in two years no
it's not gonna disappear in two years
it's safe to invest in that I think as a
result we're actually doing a better job
in both environments than we had
previously so with that I'm gonna hand
off to Dave and he's going to talk a
little bit about what we looked at for
hadoo hi everyone I am Dave I'm a staff
site reliability engineer on the data
infrastructure side so I'm going to talk
to you about the details and first of
all I'm not sure if everyone knows
Hadoop so I'll try to cover it in as few
slides as possible it's a file system
which is called HDFS it lets you run
distributed applications with an API in
runtime that's called yarn and then we
have a data processing framework or
multiple frameworks MapReduce is one
everyone has probably heard of and
there's a lot more to it in general
those principles are this it's a
distributed system so it's built from
lots of nodes or computers operating as
one it is horizontally scalable if you
want to increase your capacity in
computer or storage you just add more
nodes it's a large scale we care about
terabytes and petabytes or larger and we
care up to tens of thousands of nodes
that's the typical scale for Hadoop
Hadoop itself is fault tolerant and
self-healing so it handles failure of
machines and hardware and software
systems and it runs on commodity
hardware so that's just out of the box
but Hadoop is strategically important
for Twitter itself we use it for a large
variety of compute in the company for
example on the data side we use it to
store core data the systems and objects
such as tweets we all have all our
company logs in there we also use it for
backups and other durable storage cases
on the analytics side where we're
looking into data we do all our metrics
work there and all our aggregates
accounting sorting grouping all that
kind of stuff at large scale which is
what we're talking about here and then
we have the insight side which is where
we do things like machine learning model
training over vast datasets where we do
experiments that is both create the
experiments in a computing sense and
analyze results that we've gathered from
from other experiments we also do this
ad hoc computing or analysis in there so
somebody has a brilliant idea they write
an algorithm or a piece of code and they
want to run it generally it's a human
doing this rather than something in
super automated it's usually one-off or
irregularly needed it so talking about
Hadoop scale what are we talking what do
we have we run over a half a million
compute cores in Twitter we have over
300 petabytes of logical storage in
production and our Hadoop cluster side
we have clusters that have gone up to
12,500 nodes which is some of the
logical Hadoop clusters that we know of
publicly in terms of the sort of rate of
change of things this is just messages
that are going into Hadoop it doesn't
include every other things that
companies doing we have over a trillion
messages a day going into our Hadoop
clusters there's actually an Apache
conference talk about that if you want
to google that but the workload that we
have is broken up and here's the kind of
the way that we think about it the
cluster types going from the top down we
have our real-time clusters these are
used for very high performance critical
event processing we it's about 10% of
our compute we have our regular
scheduled processing production jobs
that's core based compute load that's
about 60% of it in the green we have our
ad hoc or one-off queries and analysis
stuff that's the stuff that's very spiky
about 30% and then we have our cold
clusters which are mostly storage we
would have very minimal computer
there and this will come up in a second
so we have challenges based on all this
kind of things that we want to do as a
company we have the challenge of scale
we have significant year-on-year
computing storage growth in the double
digits we have hardware to operate we
have to design and build and maintain an
operated we have a capacity planning
it's especially hard for us to predict
the growth of the compute in the ad hocs
case we have agility that is responding
fast to customer requests when an
internal team wants us to do something
you know to actually as storage at
compute this is especially tricky as
well also for the ad hoc case deployment
we have to get this all running we have
to keep it running it has to be able to
work at scale in the tens of thousands
size of clusters and it also has to be
able to be upgraded in flight we don't
turn these things off the network as you
can imagine we have a lot of data we
move it around between data centers as
well as inside that the clusters and we
also have to think about disaster
recovery we we keep a lot of data we
want to make sure it's durable and we
have ability to survive individual
failures
so in general we have this kind of
requirement and I want you to think
about the top two really we care about
network sustained bandwidth we can get
per core we care about the sort of bulk
part of the network we care about
sustained bandwidth procore on disk side
again its bulk we care about large
sequential reads and writes throughput
not latency and we also care about
capacity we do have to store a lot of
data so CPU and RAM are not really our
big concerns there down the list of
things we worry about in terms of
hardware and we also care about the
consistency of data sets because we are
moving around lots of files and we
consider a set of files to be a data set
and we wanted to arrive or to be
generated in one consistent way so you
can actually operate on and here's an
example of the kind of on-premise skew
that we have just very sketch of the
sort of capacity things that we got
there so they're not there's the
reasonably modest kind of hardware we
all have clusters of the range in ten to
ten thousand nodes
we're moving 225 Gnip and network and
you can see from our network numbers at
the bottom there's some particular
numbers but notice that the peaks we go
from a peak
we go from average to peak up to 10x and
that's not eight and that's not unusual
so we have lots of loads that vary quite
a lot so going back to the cloud
architecture opposite our options that
we had whenever we were looking at doing
the evaluations we could use the Hadoop
as a service that the cloud providers
gave you and we could also do our own
Twitter Hadoop on cloud of VMs for that
on the choice number two we have two
storage options that we were two storage
storage parts the durable storage which
we were not going to ever do anything
but put it on the cloud object store and
on the scratch storage so who do needs
temporary files intermediate files that
are used for calculations in during the
MapReduce steps we have choices there
with HDFS over the object store HDFS
over the block store so that's like a
filesystem approach you know the next
file system and then we can use HTTP on
local disks the local attached disks so
this is the plan that we work through we
have our baseline test that Derek was
telling you sort of establish what is
the sort of configuration that we want
to work on and the user these are all
standard who do distribution tests out
of the box you can get that measured
various low level read and write things
and things like Tara sorts is a
MapReduce application that that reads a
lot of data then short shuffles that
moves it around the network moves it
from disk into memory and back and then
it writes it all but it's very lockstep
it's very uniform it doesn't really
generate a it's a repeatable thing but
it doesn't give you something that's
actually matches what your production
workload is so so looking to the right
we were emphasizing the functional test
this is grid mix grit mix again is a
standard part of it here you it is a
capture and we used a capture of a real
production workload so we grabbed what
happened when a thousand jobs were
running on our one of our clusters one
of our production clusters and it rip
then we could replay it the reads and
writes
and the way that the job worked and
computed so we actually get a pattern
that's not so lockstep it actually
matches a production load with
overlapping jobs and some slightly
slower or longer that actually stresses
the system more realistically so the
HDFS configurations we tested we were
looking for these kind of things and all
of the Platt for the storage solutions
that we were looking for so we we wanted
a Ville ability in two regions for our
critical data and two zones for other
for intermediate data and other data the
data set consistency so this is where we
have a set of files that we want to
manipulate let's say a thousand files
form a data set because even our some of
our bigger pieces of data are just too
big to manipulate in in files mean our
our block size and in Hadoop is 512 Meg
what we typically have you know files
that are gigabytes and we have thousands
of those to form a data set so to get a
consistent view of that cloud providers
either you can use the object store and
then you cannot use the object store
with some external consistency service
those are the two choices we have so I
want to go into the hadoop evaluation
now and more depth there are two choices
for for your us on Google cloud that we
could use cloud data proc which is the
Hadoop as a service and we could use
compute engine with Twitter Hadoop stack
on top we decided to start for the
evaluation with data proc because it
could be deployed right away it was
instantly available and we didn't need
to afford any systems in order to get
running its version was similar enough
to our on-premise a dupe that we were ok
with in terms of matching what we were
going to be actually using so this is
for the evaluation and here's our actual
configuration that we use for our data
proc con testing so we worked with 800 V
CPUs in two different SKUs and one
standard eight and four but always the
800 VC be used to match what we were
capturing on-premise and we did a scale
test with 8000 V CPUs as well just to
see what we could do as a peak we
modeled average CPU in average to peak
we turned off we didn't use any pre out
of all instances because we wanted
something repeatable we wanted people to
trust the numbers we had and we chose
SKUs which you can see were roughly
match our on-premise SKUs so we were
reasonably comparing like delay and to
like
so I'm not gonna read out these slides
but if you want to know how to do this
yourself you can go through the slide
deck and have a look you how to get the
room in I don't know how you pronounce
that the way that you can do the trace
capturing stuff there's the command line
we ran to do that you can then use the
grid mix replay command which is written
there in the good mix bundle so I'm not
going to read those out but that's what
we used and here's here's the results
so first n1 standard 8 if you look at
the right-hand column we're comparing
the speed-up that we tested in our
evaluation to on premise so the first
line is using SSDs which we find was 2x
faster but it's expensive you're paying
for SSDs the other two ones are using PD
HDD so hard drive over PD persistent
disk and we tuned the compute engine
types to get the balance of network
cores and storage that we need it I
mentioned earlier about our we were
caring about our sustain network procore
and our disk i/o procore so we chose ask
you to match that and to optimize for
that and you can see we just about
matched on-premise performance and so
that tells you you know we were we are
well tuned we know what our arm premise
needs are and we built hardware to
optimize to that similarly on n1
standard 4 well it's it was a little bit
better but it's pretty much matching our
on-premise speeds and even though we
change the SKU slightly we didn't bother
testing there the third line on the
previous slide was testing without using
GCS as the durable store but it didn't
really give us anything out we do want
durability of our data so benchmark
findings application benchmarks are
critical so the MapReduce jobs that we
run have multiple steps map shuffle
putting things on local disk moving
across the network writing and doing
reducer operations and then final rites
so we recommend that you should always
rely on an application Ben British mark
like grid mix rather than doing micro
benchmarks because micro benchmarks will
give you the maximum but they will not
give you what you really need in terms
of sustained compute what is it like
working in a real and
and it's relatively easy to capture your
load of some other system and
particularly for a Google cloud we want
to emphasize that you can treat Network
stories like local disk and and this is
really important
both cloud storage and PD offered nearly
as much bandwidth as a direct attached
hard drive on-premise so comparing to
plugging in a drive network storage
equivalent and this gives you some great
opportunities so it's a big thing that
we got and that was specific to Google
cloud so we have a few functional tests
from that although we find some of the
things that we worked on live migration
which is a great feature of Google crowd
we didn't we we didn't find any any
during our Hadoop testing we didn't
notice this at all during other more
intense testing in different parts of
Twitter when they were doing a very high
requests per second test for the caches
they did notice if it was milliseconds
of things obviously we don't care so
much in who do we care about minutes of
computer and you know lots of lots of
throughput we did find some issues with
checksums which she fixed as a link to
the public JIRA where we contributed it
out within collaboration of Google and
we find a system called bug on local
SSDs which Google fixed I think I think
within 24 hours of us noticing it for so
it is very quick reactive so with that I
want to hand back over to Derek who's
going to go through the evaluation
outcomes warrants
so I think my headsets working out great
so you know I'd mentioned that we'd
looked at this across a number of
different workloads to do being only one
of those and there's a lot of temptation
certainly to get the cost to work in the
migration to do a lift and shift if
you're trying to get out of a data
center on a time line that that may be
an appropriate decision because it'll
lead to the fastest migration and
actually you know if you're worried
about duplicate costs during the
migration period that's beneficial in
the case of Twitter though when we
actually ran the analysis and especially
because we looked at such a long time
horizon post migration what we found is
that migrating to infrastructure that we
hadn't bothered to optimize for it was
pretty inefficient and it was gonna set
us up to then immediately have to do a
second migration onto something more
optimized pretty quickly with quite a
bit of time pressure because the running
running cost of that was gonna be pretty
significant so you know and of course
then we had risks around the overall
cost and risk and distraction of that
lift and shift as I'd message mentioned
before in the case of Hadoop you know it
had less dependencies on the actual you
know production environment at Twitter
so it was easier to separate which is
actually a big deal
you can draw a nice line around it and
move it without having to move
everything all at once
and especially when you when you think
about all the different supporting
systems in the data center by the time
you actually map out all those
dependencies it's actually really
attractive to to not have to bring all
those especially at the beginning it was
also very helpful that it was a standard
piece of open-source software right so
other people have already run it on the
cloud like a lot of a lot of the issues
that you might encounter have already
been addressed in our case if if we like
or don't like something it's easy to
change and then for the users on top of
our platform you know the particulars of
the infrastructure somewhat well
abstracted because you know they think
of themselves as just running on top of
Hadoop and then you know where this was
particularly interesting for us you know
we see a pretty big explosion in the
ways that people want to interact with
data especially on the ad hoc side right
it used to be that you could kind of
insist that everybody writes things a
certain way and there's a very
opinionated stack we still believe in
that for the production environment but
you know so many different people that
want to access that in so many different
ways especially on the ad hoc side that
it
very attractive to be able to put the
data in a storage system that's
separated and Google let us do that
there's also a long term bet here that
you know Google's already pretty good in
Big Data machine learning other data
related fields and they're investing a
lot they're you know more than we can
afford to do certainly and so we're
hoping to have access to that ecosystem
you know certainly I like I actually
came to the you know back when this
event was called live and it was like
2014 or something and it was like the
size of this room it's come a long way
in five years four years five years and
if it continued to grow the same way
we'd be very excited about that so
separating compute and storage for
Hadoop why was this interesting to us it
allows us to scale the different
dimensions independently as they've
mentioned the you know the relative
balance of storage and compute is pretty
different depending on our different
cluster types especially on the cold
side is very storage driven on the ad
hoc side the compute is very very spiky
and regular and hard to predict it makes
it really easy for us to separate things
into multiple different clusters and
have clusters that are more built to
purpose you know we can mix in data proc
in certain situations we can run
MapReduce and other situations we don't
have to try to figure out a way to run
six different frameworks on a ten
thousand a cluster without breaking
anything
so that's attractive we also liked the
virtual networking and project
primitives this this is actually very
nice from an organizational perspective
where we can have you know a coherent
set of teams has a piece of
infrastructure that's assigned to them
you know they're wrapped in a network
that doesn't connect anything else the
bill goes directly back to them
and we're not thinking about this as a
bill for my team anymore we're thinking
about this is you know we're helping
them run infrastructure that's serving
their needs and they're getting billed
for it directly it's also a lot easier
to manage because a lot of the state
lives in the object store so deployments
you know there's still some state in the
cluster but like deploying is a lot
easier than it would be when you have to
upgrade thousands and thousands of nodes
in place without breaking anything right
you can spin up another cluster next to
it you can use that for testing and it's
a huge enabler there but you know also
for rolling upgrades and stuff it's a
pretty beneficial and it's nice for us
to treat storage as commodity we have a
lot of disks and it's it's I
actually very excited about not even had
to worry about that quite as much
anymore although we will still continue
have quite a few of them I think I hit
the wrong button there there we go
so here's you know we're looking at
moving the cold and ad-hoc clusters you
know I think I mentioned this before the
production is staying in the data center
for the cold cluster it's pretty
straightforward we're gonna use the
cloud storage in our case actually we
access the data enough that we're
expecting most of this will just be
standard storage we're not going to be
using the you know the colder storage
tiers too much we don't think although
those may prove interesting to us in the
future
this is also an environment where data
proc works nicely because you know when
we do run a job here it's it's usually
pretty transitory and you know scaling
is almost entirely storage driven on the
ad hoc side we're gonna do it a little
bit differently we're gonna actually run
Twitter hood you up there and here's the
stack that we're gonna use so you know
we're running on GCE using our version
of Hadoop there's a couple benefits to
this one is it minimizes the amount of
difference between on-premises and the
cloud so that when we go to move jobs
that's gonna be more straightforward we
also believe that we can get better
efficiencies there we run at pretty high
CPU and memory utilization on our
clusters and get quite a bit of cost
advantage from that and we're looking to
preserve that where possible we are
interested in using bigquery and data
flow to some extent for our scale we've
had trouble figuring out a way to get
bigquery to be cost cost-effective for
us so we're using that tactically for
use cases where bigquery is particularly
well-suited but we do not have a
broad-based
adopt bigquery for everything strategy
by any means so the node config that we
were we ended up using actually for for
v1 here is actually pretty
straightforward it looks like an n1
standard 8 we're not planning to use the
preemptable VMs or auto scaling to begin
with all of these are interesting things
that I expect that we will explore in
time however yeah so I mentioned that
our production workloads are staying on
premises there's a couple reasons for
that you might ask you know if one runs
well why not the other there's a lot
more production dependencies there
we'd have to pull a lot more stuff with
that that's a lot harder to tease out it
also increases our risk if we do that
because you know we're building a pretty
large scale environment there's a lot of
you know unique things that we're gonna
do to get this working we would love not
to have hard core production
dependencies on this infrastructure
especially in the near term the
production environment has a lot more
regular CPU usage right these are
scheduled jobs that run the same way all
the time
we can build hardware that's very well
suited to that we can restrict people to
fewer run times that are you know most
price performant that's all much more
reasonable and we think that we can but
we still think that we can support that
more efficiently on-premises
strategically what does this do for
Twitter you know it gets us to a next
generation architecture for this part a
piece of our stack which we're very
excited about we're gonna be able to
leverage capacity and and Ardie from
Google that you know we don't have to
carry the full cost of that ourselves
you know we like a model where we're
investing in the things that are key to
us but when we have you know kind of
smaller teams that want something that
you know maybe we can't forward to spin
up a full team you know of a Google type
scale you know that we have a vendor
solution available there we like
participate in larger ecosystem you know
it's nice to be here with all of you
we're looking to learn from you and you
know get access to more things and you
know kind of what we've done in our data
center so far we like the idea of having
a strategic collaboration with Google
and you know there's quite a few other
Twitter teams that are gonna do
something with the cloud many of them
are much smaller than we are
but by having our team go first we
basically you know establish that
relationship get everything kind of
going for Twitter make it really easy to
move data there get it easy to spin up
services they're all the kind of
plumbing work that needs to happen and
then the idea is that many of those
teams can now make a little bit more
localized decision about whether they
run in the cloud or the data center
whereas before that was hard to do in a
localized way so you know we get a
couple benefits from this doing like
large-scale ad hoc analysis and
backfills gets a lot easier when you can
leverage that capacity so cold for
example doesn't use very much CPU until
all of a sudden you have to rewrite
everything and
I'm very excited for the capacity
problem there to not be mine we avoid
HDFS limits you know like like on the
name node for example we have a copy of
our data now off-site which is
attractive you know tape backups for us
it's not really viable so this this
actually is it makes a lot easier for
people to get at the cold data and we're
excited to do more analysis there on the
platform side you know we were we have a
minority of workloads that benefit from
some sort of compliance regime and
that's a little bit easier to support on
Google we like the direct charge back
that I mentioned for projects retention
management's a little simpler with some
of the tools that Google provides and
you know we're excited to start
exploring some more that ecosystem so
I'm sure a lot of people here are doing
migrations your probably wondering what
a migration looks like at Twitter in
some ways that's probably similar in
some ways a little different so we have
a Google PSO team that's on site with us
a pretty good sized team and they're
working with us on a day to day basis
helping us with the migration it's been
actually kind of a nice marriage you
know we have a lot of engineers that
know a lot about Twitter and the
specific software that we're using the
Google PSO team knows a lot about
Google's infrastructure and so so far I
think it's been a nice marriage there
the network connectivity is a little
different probably than what other
people are doing given our scale we
needed to do pni with Google so we're
doing 800 gig total connectivity this is
just for Hadoop this isn't for Twitter
in general this is just for our
workloads so that's our network
exclusively and we're copying data into
a whole bunch of different buckets in
most cases there's a roughly one-to-one
mapping between a data set and a bucket
for us which makes the Apple management
very simple so we're gonna have a lot of
buckets and it's actually nice that
that's very easy to do as I mentioned
we're gonna be splitting ad hoc and
compute we're also going to be doing
more smaller clusters than we do in the
data center so I think our largest ad
hoc cluster is something like 6500 nodes
at the moment that's going to go to you
know we're gonna split that into 3 or 4
clusters to start with and then possibly
more later we are making internal teams
owners of these clusters and buckets
that's a little bit easier to do given
the cloud infrastructure so when it's a
on-premise infrastructure and you're a
platform team that owns it
you know the idea of giving somebody
rude on the box that you're
administering is a little terrifying you
know there's a lot more that we can do
there that's you know more flexibly on
the cloud I am has actually taken a fair
bit of work we're not doing anything
that complicated we're a Google Apps
user and we use LDAP but it's actually
taken quite a bit of work to figure out
how to do that some of that is because
we're doing secure clusters as part of
this which is more complicated than the
typical migration and then we're
constantly upgrading updating the
migration capacity plans we're still
pretty early in that process so
completion is a ways away we have found
some limits you know quite literally
there's a limits page and we find that
we're asking to get those increased
quite a lot you know we found also that
you know our internal operating model of
like 10,000 dead clusters is not
something other people seem to be doing
on the cloud I don't know how many other
people are doing that in the data center
either you know but we're trying to
adapt somewhat and run smaller clusters
there for scaling scaling up works okay
scaling down is a little bit of an
unsolved problem so we're not confident
we're gonna achieve a ton of elasticity
in the very near term and then you know
we do do some amount of joint capacity
planning for Google I'd say you know
order of you know 10,000 cores is you
know you get some encouragement to talk
to them advance and order you know
10,000 core surprise asks you get a lot
of encouragement to talk to them in
advance so what are we doing now
we've got the network set up we're doing
a lot of work with I am
we actually have dedicated clusters just
for the replication those are set up and
running we're in the process of standing
up the clusters you know the proof of
concept clusters on the cloud that are
gonna be the you know the first instance
of the real cluster and then we have a
whole bunch of supporting management
software around it that we're building
out we're copying petabytes out of the
cloud you know our ongoing copies gonna
be you know petabytes a day plus there's
the 300 that we have to do up front we
did have one early use case that we
pulled forward this has actually been a
pretty fun one we had an internal team
with a sort of short-term need for this
use case we learned a lot from this
actually I'd love to give a full talk on
this at some point in the future so we
surprised Google with the 10,000 100,000
core ask
minute and then we started hammering GCS
with it it's been a cool learning
experience we have about a 15 petabytes
at that we're querying with presto there
and it's taking a little work but it's
it's going and then you know we've also
been learning a lot about the cloud
storage connector and working with that
team very closely so I'll give a couple
recommendations for you and then some
conclusions for us the recommendations
for you of the tests that we ran I would
highly encourage you to do the
application benchmarking and and the
scale testing some of that seems like it
you know may have been a bit of a no op
on Google right it's kind of similar
performance on from do I really need to
do this you know we haven't talked about
all the places that we ran these tests
and mileage does vary depending on where
you run this so many of the findings
here are true for Google in particular
not for the cloud in general and these
are the tests that will allow you to
discover that when you compare pricing
this is actually also kind of a
fundamental one there's a temptation to
say you know I have an eight-core box
with you know whatever 64 gigs of ram
I'm gonna go to the pricing pull the
page I'm gonna see how much that cost
there and that's gonna be my price
comparison the performance
characteristics are different enough
that for any meaningful workload like
this that's not a fair comparison of
costs and we much prefer having done the
application level benchmarking to
compare the cost of running a workload
on both environments and then allow
yourself to architect it properly and
take advantage of you know better or
worse performance as it occurs for
example you know when you do the you
know eight cores and 64 gigs on both
sides you've completely ignored the
network which is like kind of secretly
one of the most important pieces it
doesn't show up on your bill but it
affects your bill massively so you know
make sure that as you're testing this
and clearing this you're looking at
those types of things in terms of
migration planning you know I think
you'll get negotiated in to lift and
shift and that may be the right answer
if you're getting out of a data center
but you know in our case we benefited a
lot from you know it did take two years
to come up with exactly what we're gonna
do and move forward with it but I think
we have a much smarter plan than we
would have otherwise which is balancing
some short-term value with speed of
execution than unlimited risk
so conclusions that we drew you know
some of these were were interesting
findings for us you know if the network
is good enough locality matters less and
that's very interesting for certain
categories of workload Google's network
is pretty good so what Cali doesn't
matter as much there when the compute
side of things get stateless it's a lot
easier to manage and you know being able
to treat PD like local HDD is very
empowering for a lot of things and this
one in particular is not true everywhere
cloud adoption is quite complex so you
can imagine the surface graph at Twitter
is quite complicated and it's very
difficult to disentangle that and figure
out exactly what you can move that's a
big problem it takes a lot of thinking
the architectural choices themselves are
somewhat non-obvious right there's
various trade-offs and costs and it
takes quite a bit of analysis to figure
out what to do there and and because of
both of those things it's well worth
claiming to spend some time doing the
analysis and then you know I think the
the concluding thought here is we're
very new to this process a lot of you
are probably farther along with Google
than we are we're excited to learn from
you at the conference so if you're doing
something at similar scale especially
and they're further along I would love
to get your business card but you know
hopefully we'll be here next year and we
will have actually completed at least
portions of this migration we'll be able
to give some technical talks on kind of
more specific things that we've done and
yeah we're looking forward to being part
of the community
[Music]